parliament welcomes italy's president
giorgio napolitano staunch europhile and
former mep talked about the importance
of the euro with just three months to go
before the european elections the
president also brought up the challenges
the eu has to tackle vis-a-vis winning
over young people
a reformed
facing strong opposition from several
member states and financial experts a
financial transaction tax negotiations
have been deadlocked for months there
has even been an about phase from some
of the countries who were initially in
favor of introducing the tax
it now looks unlikely that the text will
be adopted in 2014.
meps took stock of recent developments
in a debate with the council and
commission
commanders
it's estimated that financial
transaction tax could yield 30 to 35
billion euros a year
so far only 11 countries are set to
introduce ftt through enhanced
cooperation artists will enjoy better
protection from collecting societies in
europe with music often sold via
internet platforms it's difficult or
even impossible for artists to enforce
their rights and claim the money owed
from around europe
mep's approved multi-territorial
licensing which will be valid in all 28
member states
not only is this a step forward for
music providers consumers will also have
a much wider range of online music at
their fingertips
these reforms allow there to be much
greater transparency
in collection
of royalties on behalf of authors and
people who have created and thereby
allowing them to carry on developing
their creations
each year the music industry brings in 6
billion euros in europe